so um you wrote a book before this one
called the three trillion dollar war
about Iraq and I'm wondering you know
the term opportunity cost comes up I
mean yeah I read about it a lot in your
book like what would have happened if we
took that money and spent it like say in
Baltimore in places like that so just
tell me a little about that the
opportunity cost and is it still true
truth trillion or not when we wrote the
book we knew that that was an unrest
amount that the true cost was greater
but we wanted to be credible because
some people remember President Bush said
it was going to cost
altogether sixty billion dollars and we
were spending that amount every few
months by the way what else in America
can you be that wrong about you know
with from sixty billion to three or four
trillion whatever it is now that that's
that's a lot of wrong that that makes a
couple zeros yeah but but just to give
you one one one example of how we were
conservative the cost of the disabled
coming back to the United States right
we thought it would be around 40% it's
been closer to 50% of those who who went
to Afghanistan and Iraq are coming back
with multiple disabilities and the cost
of that the disability the health care
just that is over a trillion dollars Wow
you